[music]
>> If footwear are not allowed, wear only
clean and torn socks. You know, many
times people wear socks
which are torn. Who's going to watch?
And when it says that shoes not allowed,
so you walk in with your big toe coming
out.
In that case, you remove your socks.
Better remove your socks.
If footwear is not allowed, wear clean
and torn socks.
Do not wear neck chains or
wrist chains.
Not that I don't like it, but this
distracts. Imagine if you're wearing a
chain.
Gold chain is haram for the men. Even if
you wear a silver chain, forget about
gold. Silver chain, and then, a is
coming at it and it's
And you're doing something action and
there's a chain, big chain coming here.
And you're doing an action and then you
can see that and that is flashing in
somebody's eyes.
All these are distractions.
I mean, I'm going on a higher level.
All this will count
if you want to become
a die par excellence.
And all these count when you have that
ability.
And once you go on a very high level,
all these things don't count because
your skills
overshadow everything else.
Once you become
an expert,
you can break most of the rules and yet
be effective.
You can
break most of the rules and yet be
effective. We'll come to it later on.
But,
avoid wearing chains,
all the things which will
distract the audience and your talk.
Avoid wearing glamorous things like
shining watches, rings, etc.
Do not wear belts with big showy
buckles.
There are many a time that youngsters,
you know, they wear belts which are
absolutely big and again shining and
give a different appearance.
If you're wearing
beneath the suit, no problem.
I'm talking when you're wearing formal
clothes like a shirt and pant. As I
said, formal will keep on changing.
You've been wearing a thobe which is
good is formal. Or
in Malaysia, they have that
they're wearing
What's it called?
Something.
That's formal.
The formal dress keeps on changing.
You go to Africa, in Nigeria, they wear
different.
They wear somewhat like a thobe with a
different color.
You go to Indonesia, they have the batik
print.
Which I personally don't like, but it's
good for them. It's a formal dress.
Number eight, button your shirt. Except
for collar button, all the other buttons
should be closed if you're not wearing a
suit. It's very important.
Normally, the buttons should be closed.
Imagine if you're leaving the top two,
three. Top button, if you're not wearing
a suit, top button open is normal. It
should be opened. If you're wearing a
suit and a tie, then the top button
should be closed, but the other buttons,
many people have a habit, at least in
this part of the world, that they keep
below the collar button, the first and
they keep it open. Because they want to
show that they're macho. They want to
show the hair on the chest.
It doesn't give a good appearance.
Many things I'm telling now
were observed by me on the second day
when people came.
So, you yourself should analyze.
I'll ask who did that. So, you should
say that. If you say I, that means you
have realized.
Many things I'll say
which have been done by one or more of
you
or more than one. Some have been done by
almost all of you.
So, the buttoning is very important. It
gives that
casual
and unwanted look.
Do not fold your sleeves while
lecturing. And, what I'm telling, all
these things have been done umpteen
number of times. Not by normal people,
by many people who give Islamic lectures
in different parts of the world. So, I'm
not telling you something which is just
coming out of my head. It's my
experience.
And, people even wearing suits as seen.
It looks good.
As if I'm going for a fight.
And, I'm not joking, really.
You may ask,
is Zakir making us a model? No, I'm not
making you a model.
I don't want you to be a model. I want
to be a model Muslim, alhamdulillah.
So, when you give me a talk, it looks
like I'm going for a fight.
And believe me, speakers in suit doing
this. I don't want to name them.
Again, when you wear your little bit,
depending upon your sleeve, little bit
shirt can be seen.
Point number 10, do not keep
anything, not even a pen in your shirt
pocket. Do not clutter your trouser
pockets with things not required.
It's very common
that people keep a pen here.
And the pen is seen, and imagine
it may be a shiny pen, or it may be
you're wearing a white shirt and a blue
pen. That's very prominent. Don't give
prominence to anything besides yourself.
Not your pen.
A person looks at a pen, what's the
advantage for you? And the eye is very
powerful. And if it's being recorded, so
don't have anything.
And if you require a pen, keep it on the
table.
The people stuff their pockets with a
keychain, and then you know
and here and there.
Imagine if I keep all this over here,
and if I give a talk, how does it look?
It's very common.
And even the day before yesterday,
how many people had pen in their
pockets? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
Again, all these points are just
points, not that
it's haram or something.
Small points, but make a difference.
Very small points.
All these points, one one one points put
together,
it's not required.
If you require for writing, keep it on
the table.
And don't clutter your pocket,
especially with a very big handkerchief.
And when I when I travel, I do have a
lot of things in my pocket normally. You
know, my visiting card, and my one
mobile here, one mobile here. But when I
go for the talk, it's all either kept in
the room
where I don't like keeping mobiles on
the table, just in case I forget, very
precious. I give it to one of my
friends. Even now, the moment I go out,
my mobile will be inside. And I come on
the streets, I give it to my friend. Now
I don't have anything.
Imagine mobile coming and suddenly tring
tring and suddenly it starts vibrating.
Giving a talk, you don't want to be
disturbed. So no mobile, nothing. Not
even vibrating mode.
Imagine if a call comes and say I'm
sorry, you know, and I keep speaking.
How do you like it? Oh, how are you?
Where are you?
Oh, I'm here just having a double
training session here and all the people
are here. How are you? What are you
doing? When are you coming here?
It's common that people even talk on the
mobile.
While speaking.
And some people, if the bell rings, they
have to pick up. It is their nature.
Irrespective, they may not know their
name, have to pick up. They'll leave
everything in the world to pick up that
phone.
It is the nature. We are doing something
which is important.
So see to it that you don't clutter.
Keep yourself free.
So that you can concentrate and don't
distract the people with the things they
are cluttering with.
Point number 11.
If spectacles are worn,
then the frame should not be glamorous.
Glamorous.
And now
the times are changing.
You know, because
we have sessions in our school.
And the school children from the age of
four, they give talks.
Now, if you go to an optician
or go to optical shop,
you will find most of the frames are all
fancy and funky is the right word.
Purple, pure white and this is black.
Yellow.
To get a simple full black frame is
difficult to get in the market.
Same thing, you wear jeans, you have got
one pocket here, one pocket there, one
pocket there. If it's a boy, okay, you
wear a normal trouser with normal
pockets, it's is available.
So what do you do? We buy a suit and we
use the trouser only. What to do?
You can't get simple trousers. The
trouser has to have at least four
pockets and behind two and three and
little bit torn in between, so it is
more expensive.
You know, if it's torn in between, it's
more money. And if it's a little bit
scrubbed
scrubbed a little bit, you know,
stone washed.
Stone washed. So the cost goes double.
So specs should be normal. Not
particular size, but don't make it too
glamorous
and too fluorescent color and not very
big frames.
And if the video recording is being done
while you're speaking,
it's preferable
that the glasses
have an anti-glare coating.
Anti-glare coating means when anything
reflects, it's more comfortable for me
and while the shooting is going on,
it gets reflected and
the chances of the glare coming is
minimized, not completely cannot be
removed.
It is minimized.
And that's not very expensive. Having
anti-glare coatings are expensive.
And you can easily identify whether the
glasses anti-glare or not. How many
people glasses anti-glare is there?
Anyone?
1 2 3 4 5
To know it's anti-glare or not, you take
out your glass
and you keep it against the light
and the reflection you see
would be
green or blue depending upon the
coating.
You will not find the normal yellow
light being reflected. It gets diffused
and
it is
greenish. So the white light or the
yellow light becomes green or becomes
blue depending upon the coating.
I'm not talking about photochromatic
glasses.
Do you know what photochromatic glasses?
Who knows photochromatic glasses?
Photochromatic glasses mean when you go
in the sun, it becomes dark.
So that you don't see the glare.
When you come in the
shade, it become normal.
I personally don't like one side
projected. Why? No, it's not haram. You
can wear it.
Because when you go out, you look like a
don. It becomes dark, and I'm not
realizing it's dark.
And I don't like looking like a don.
I personally, it's nothing to do with
public speaking.
It becomes completely black.
And I don't like wearing those goggles
personally. It's my personal choice. It
has nothing to do with public speaking.
But, if your talk is being recorded,
it's preferable that you wear
anti-glare, so that's better for you
also, and better for the recording.
There's no reflection. But, if there's a
reflection on your specs, you know what
will happen? There'll be a yellow patch
here.
And if the cameraman is not good, big
patches, two big patches. And when
someone is seeing your recording, it'll
look like
You know what it'll look? Imagine yellow
patches on your glasses.
So this anti-glare coating
reduces
the glare
and the reflection to a great extent.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Ar-Rahman, as-S
Allah Oh
Ya Oh